what a strange risk to take in a way
like i don't think
that a lot of shows probably wouldn't be
okay with this
there is no other late night where this
would have ever happened
there's no chance a lot of people don't
take these bigger risks where
you know perhaps someone does pull them
into a meeting if this thing flops
you know and you having the confidence
in in john to begin with and then myself
and then
conan for being you know willing to put
his name on it
is it truly is a a a big deal
it's almost that when someone puts their
faith in you now you go well now i can't
fail
i can't let this it's like when you have
a good boss when you have a good boss
you just work hard because you're like i
just don't want to disappoint them it's
not even about the money or the job
you're like
hi he's just such a good guy just before
we came back from commercial jeff ross
and i are standing out
on the stage where we always do at the
podium and he looks at me and goes
i've got a bad feeling about this that's
all you said
[Laughter]
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome
john doerr and rory scoville
[Music]
i had seen you uh in montreal at the
just for last comedy festival
do something with reggie watts that blew
my mind yes so you would have seen
at just for laughs reggie now rory was
at that just for last festival and then
if rory was available it would have been
rory and i doing that
one time in montreal where me you and
reggie did a three-person
uh a three-person version of this oh i
didn't remember that and it was so
difficult to do and reggie was sort of
behind us with the keyboard and i think
i don't remember if he had his uh
looper or not but yeah it was very very
difficult
he would have upstaged us literally um
yeah
he would have been well i would have
been like can we just watch reggie can
you guys get out of the way
exactly that's what i would have been
doing why are these two guys talking
these guys are ruining reggie's set
i had done like the idea i remember
being at the
bridgestown comedy festival and then uh
james adomian and i performed it
together
because there there was like maybe
13 people in a theater and so it didn't
feel right to just go up and try and
give it your all and do
a traditional set so yeah we
experimented with it there
um and then i'd done it with i think
lynn shaw croft and reggie watts but
rory obviously was someone that
i think we just trust each other
instinctively on stage so it was always
fun
to do with rory in a way um that was a
little more fun than doing it with
anyone else
so yeah i think he'll probably get into
this but i don't think we really
prepared much
for the better product you almost can't
practice it yeah
the moment you go to listen to the other
person you're done yeah you almost don't
want to know what they're going to say
because you don't want to have any track
record in your mind of where they might
be at in their
you know their version you can't make
mistakes if there's no script to follow
is good too the only thing we knew there
were very general notes like obviously
i was there's a guitar involved that
gets broken and then rory is going to do
improv
with an audience member so we know we're
working to that but we had very general
rules
i remember like i'll go loud you go
quiet
you go loud i go quiet and that was
pretty much it and i watched this set
today for the first time in forever
leading up to this and there are some
like
genuinely really funny things that
happen and coincidences
that happen yeah moments where words pop
up and happen and it's always different
whenever we would do it live
but yeah that was a pretty special
taping
because things happened that have never
happened before i think what's amazing
about is that ultimately on the surface
it really is just
one joke to laugh at it's just the setup
yes somewhere
you know people come out and it's like
oh we heard the setup from conan who
delivered it
so perfectly that millions of people
thought it was real
and then you and then when you come out
and you facilitate that setup
it's almost like everything after that
hearing a word here and there or a
really crazy uh sentence or
john you know breaking the guitar or the
woman coming up to do the arms thing
those are just added bonuses to that uh
overall
joke you know because really there's no
ending to that
joke i mean it really all just ends and
that's a great point like conan
sells it so well this doesn't happen
often in our business but
we have tonight accidentally double
booked comedians
for the show and uh yeah we we booked
them
both for the same night uh i am sorry i
don't know how this happened
and i guarantee it will not happen again
it's very unprofessional
and you'd think i'd know better after
all these years and my team would know
better
but this happened so rather than
rescheduling
uh one of our comics this is interesting
they have both graciously agreed
to share their time tonight it almost
feels beautiful when he says they've
agreed to share their time like
what what charitable comedians they're
traditionally so
selfish and that now they've agreed to
share their time
and then it is a one note joke that gets
repeated and that's why we have to up
the ante a little bit you
guys are both two of the bravest people
i know on stage
we're just dumb well anytime jeff can
lean into your ear and go i don't like
this
then something right has happened you
got something good
you're getting bravery you're getting
[Music]
all right yeah look at this crowd
you know what i mean i won't flush the
toilet on an airplane because of the
noise like it scares me
you go you hit flush then you turn
around nothing happens for five seconds
then out of nowhere
oh my god my upper register is really
annoying
i know my but i think that's my attempt
at okay i go loud first
rory goes quiet and then i can feel
myself settle into after that joke
settle into quiet talk and just hear
rory go boom
boom it's all happening so in my head
there's like three trains of thought
there well there's four
one is i'm gonna die one day that's
always there and then
one of them is rory's going quiet i
should go loud and then it's me
remembering what i'm saying and it's
like holy [ __ ] we're on tv
i just put a hole in the plant
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
and maybe it wasn't the best idea to put
three sixth graders in charge of the
major crimes division
just because they're good think about it
[Applause]
growing up in south carolina fighting
chinese kids
rory when you do you do
i'm sorry i missed the joke it's a
little lost in there
but when you're doing the joke where you
say grow up in north carolina fighting
chinese kids is that a joke that you
would do in your set
at that time that was uh yeah there was
a time when they were remaking karate
kids right
oh right people being mad about that
yeah yeah
so then when in your set would you act
it out with that kind of
volume gusto yeah i i think to your
point
you kind of start to clue in on when to
go up and when to come down
yeah and i think in your i think at
least in my mind
anytime there's a moment to be sort of
physically big or a little bit louder
it's like
you should do it because it's almost
like yeah it's almost like hitting the
symbol or it's almost like you know
hitting yeah yeah yeah
you almost choose the bits that require
the least amount of like
layers to it you just want to know like
okay i
all i have to remember is i'm talking
about how loud the toilet is on the
airplane
no one's catching the minutia so the
minutiae doesn't matter
if the joke requires the minutia then
it's almost like a waste of time because
they can't hear it and you don't want to
remember it
i'm just glad that i've been able to
know that they were mexican i didn't
know that
i didn't know that and they didn't know
that i didn't know that's my
terrible
[Applause]
i think we've exhausted the idea for a
tv for a tv set of doing material
yeah and now it's like elevated to make
it so ridiculous
it's almost perfect that about halfway
through this
something changes and i mean a guitar
coming out catches everyone's attention
you can't you still haven't caught up
with the fact like what are each of them
[ __ ] saying
and then now there's a guitar and then a
random audience member comes up they're
like
even more like that you can't keep up
with we must have been getting
uh cues from the floor director at this
point like this must be
one minute left or a minute and a half
left or because i i definitely remember
there was a point where it's like okay
time to get into the guitar
or time for rory to get in i can't
remember if who was working off of
hugh's
who's i was i was following you the
whole time like
i knew that i wasn't going to get rid of
her until you smashed that guitar
if i could just get somebody from the
audience a lot of people laughs guys
give her a round of applause get up here
learn to play guitar
okay a lot of people ask me how do you
sally you guys what she's going to do is
she's going to put her arms behind me
it's called arms experts a lot of fun
just have fun with it i got anal warts
while at guitar camp okay what are we
doing
i imagine all the uh all the attention
shifting to rory here
and so all the setup of the guitar and
whatever is gone so then here's another
example of them just getting igadi in
awards
on its own which is just which is
perfect
and it's just happening it's just
organically happening no no this is
planned
do you think the woman who came up and
did the arms thing wouldn't you love to
know that she's like skyrocketed like
her career is just
incredible how was she involved
was she just asked her okay so she was a
legit audience member i don't even
audience member yeah we went i grabbed
rory before just after they had sat the
audience
and he and i stood side of you know side
of the stage we saw
a young girl who just seemed like she
was really having fun with the warm-up
and rory just walked up to her and said
hey
would you be open to being a part of
something and she didn't really i mean
right she didn't know that much about
what she was gonna get into when i said
it's gonna be this and she was like oh
i've seen that so i kind of know and i
was like i'm just gonna be talking to
you like so i will be
literally saying exactly what you you
know hey come up here hey stand here do
that like
but i if you really step back and look
at it from her perspective
what an insane afternoon
like if john and i were even slightly
nervous about
doing this thing imagine this woman
who's like well i guess i'm going to be
on conan tonight
and what are we doing right we're
throwing anyway we're dancing
we're dancing we're dancing right now
we're out on the beach
now we're driving well big steering
wheel geez geez
[Music]
lots of traffic lots of traffic i don't
know what's going on i don't know enough
spaghetti you can't eat pill no no no no
no no
if you do both pills you'll die
do not mix your pits i'm just throwing
it i'm still driving in the toilet
[Applause]
is some of the stool broken off yes i
chipped the stool yeah
it like you did right yeah i mean it was
poorly constructed
that stool but yeah uh those two hands
coming up at the end like it's just so
fun how this one worked out and then how
we close here which
people don't know but we're still in the
bid
[Music]
and really incredible incredible job
so gracious uh john dora rory scoville
uh that was great uh where
where can people catch you guys live oh
well i'm gonna be
in atlanta at the theater july 14th of
the next night in africa we will
take a break we will be right back thank
you very much guys
something that no one is is really aware
of is what was going on backstage
yeah this day oh remember
this was the day a lot of comics came
down because they heard you guys were
doing this
so nick thune being one of them yeah and
there was a group gathered backstage
because they just needed to witness what
you were doing
that led to a lot of free time on on
their hands
it led to a very elaborate practical
joke being played on another comedian
mm-hmm that's right i'm uncomfortable
talking about this
but i have a funny feeling was this was
this the same day
or was it the yeah it was sure it was
the same day yeah i'll say this you know
what i'm disappointed about
with this uh rory was definitely the
conscience
and i i feel like you were uncomfortable
with it and rightfully so
um thune was definitely excited about
trying to do a prank like this the
problem with this prank was that
we were not uh making someone think
something horrible was going to happen
and then give them a sense of relief by
letting them know the world is fine
we were promising them something fun and
exciting
and then taking that away from them
which was that's not good
that's true that's the flaw in this
practical joke when you look back you go
it wasn't the right thing to do
but what for everyone wondering we
rory we're out of time we're out of time
lacey mclaughlin says i had subtitles on
and it gave up halfway through
i tell you what that's actually a good
point to watch it with subtitles i think
that's
insane that's really funny
berto garcia says this is their act they
do this everywhere
it's not funny it's lazy
well i agree with the last part it is
it is lazy but it is lazy but it is
funny
and it's really fun to do which is the
most important thing
in my mind yeah i love when someone says
something isn't funny and you can
watch it and undeniably there are people
laughing at it
but also you're allowed not to love it i
mean great i mean be
yeah yeah i just love people's own
opinions becomes the definitive
statement of a thing like this isn't
funny
okay but but it's the phrase
uh they do this everywhere it's not
funny so
it's them saying this what i think
they're buying into a little bit of the
intro like
don't be fooled by this double bulky
double booking nonsense
they do this they've done this before
and i don't like it
you're right
it's so strange to come to realize that
this is a decade but a decade this
september or november i can't remember
no it's 2011 yeah it'll be decade yeah
this september i would say
it's been an overwhelming positive
response i've seen people tell people
they need to watch it and
people have come up and asked me about
it you know 10 years
later this truly this dumb this dumb
thing that
you know we got to do that you guys let
us do people still
really hold it up as something special
and i i you know for me
i think it's special i hadn't been on a
late night thing and i'm performing with
my friend and it's
this crazy thing so i think it's special
so
it's pretty cool when someone else you
know feels that way too about it and
they're just a part of the audience yeah
i think it's the kind of thing
i mean everything rory said it was so
fun to do it felt different
and it was something we could do
together that we've tested before and it
also felt like if it goes wrong who
cares like there's it just felt like
and it's rare that if something like
that which is don't get me wrong being
on conan and doing stand-up is
so precious and important and fun and
it's like a notch on the belt
and it's that thing you look forward to
so you do feel lucky
but in order for this thing to work out
you kind of have to just fly by the
cedar pants so
uh it was so fun it was really fun to do
in one of those ways where
you know the prep for it laughing and
giggling backstage and being loose and
treating
conan's backstage green room set like
you would a regular green room which is
just
jokes and silliness and other comics
dropping by and
practical jokes and i don't know like
the culture there
is so supportive of silliness and
goofiness so i i love it and traveling
around comedians the response is great
like people seem to say that thing you
and rory did was so fun and
they call i don't know and people come
up with names for it which is
interesting they'll say like dueling
comics i'm like
never called this anything right yeah
but it's so interesting
and uh thank you jp by the way for uh
letting us do it because
it was a ball i should say thank you but
i but i can't and i won't